i have to ask first and foremost were
there tortillas backstage and did
anything get out of hand for a moment
there were tortillas
and they were all um organic
and that's important
[Music]
so what i do now because i lost but yet
i won in a good way the tortilla
challenge against kevin i carry
tortillas with me everywhere i go
in case somebody wants some smoke
maybe somebody wants some tortilla smoke
i don't want no tortilla smoke all right
that was a dream come true for him by
the way and by the way we didn't we had
no idea first of all a few things
never heard of the tortilla challenge
until that moment our day was done and
uh
our vp of social came up and she said
hey there's a challenge you want to do a
tortilla challenge she told us what it
was i said sure let's do it.
never thinking that i was going to lose
and get the slapped out of me with a
tortilla
it was a lot of fun though it's a dream
come true for him what do you kiddos
think of you doing that hopping on
trends and stuff like that do they think
it's funny or they're like dad you're
too old for that no i mean they're six
and four so you know they don't they
don't know and my 20 year old she's
kicking ass and doing their thing so uh
but it was a lot of fun
try it i co you have not played it have
you no and i have a seven year old but
he punches like a mule kicking downhill
so i don't want any of do it get some
um talk about black adam real quick we
got to see black adam come out in the
costume followed by the rock coming out
to talk about it it was a magical
experience in hall h and i really felt
like it meant something to you in this
cast thank you man i appreciate that it
was a it was a uh it was a moment
because you know coming back here to
comic con hall h
uh you know and i've been doing this
dance for some time uh throughout my
career and coming to comic-con bringing
a lot of movies to comic-con you hope
the crowd likes it
you never know
but the dream has always been to come to
comic-con
and represent a superhero represent a dc
movie i was a dc kid growing up now i'm
a i'm still a dc kid
now as a man but
no so that was a real dream come true
and to be there hall h 6 000 people um
everyone going crazy and you know the
goal was if we're going to go and again
this has been like a 20 plus year dream
so we're going to go let's make it
special let's really deliver something
that's different and unique for the fans
and warner brothers in dc when we were
having our meetings with seven bucks
productions they said well what do you
think what's different well get the
costume ready
because i'm gonna get in that costume
and we're gonna levitate oh my goodness
and before you walk away
best thing and worst thing about the
costume
uh
the best thing about the costume wound
up being
[Music]
removing all the muscle pads
in the costume true story like two and a
half three years ago when the costume
makers first came over to hawaii where i
was and they brought me this costume and
they're the best in the business right
they make all the superhero costumes i
put it on
and it had all the muscle padding in it
and if as you know you're in shape you
train a lot of people out there
understand you put muscle padding over
muscle well then your muscle goes away
and i was like well this is ridiculous
i've worked too hard i've worked my butt
off for this so we removed the muscle
padding out of the costume so now it's
like just a latex fit on me
and um
so that was the best part and the worst
part
um
not the worst part man
not the worst part
you